&gt;&gt; Well, it looks like we're only at 12,000 Hz right now, Andy.
&gt;&gt; Yeah, and it looks like they are all able to hear that. Lauren, when can we
expect to see contestants to drop off?
&gt;&gt; Well, the range for human hearing is between 20 hertz and 20,000 hertz. So, if
I had to put my money on it, I would guess we'd see people drop off at around
17,000 to 18,000 Hz. And for those of you trying to compete at home, I'd
recommend turning your sound up, closing your eyes, and trying to see which of
these tones you can identify it.
[SOUND].
&gt;&gt; That was really exciting Andy.
&gt;&gt; It was. Let's see if we can talk to the winner as they prepare for the next
event. Susan, are you there?
&gt;&gt; Hi Andy, I can hear you loud and clear. You must be talking between 20 and
20,000 hertz, right? I've got the winner here of the pitch absolute threshold
competition, Jacques. That was incredible, how did you do it?
&gt;&gt; Well, I've always taken good care of my ears.
&gt;&gt; Well, thank you and congratulations. I'll let you go ahead and prepare for your
next event. Back to you, Lauren and Andy.
&gt;&gt; Thanks Susan. We're going to take a brief break, and get a word from one of our
sponsors while the next event is being prepared.